[Musique]
avec wolfram bien sûr bonjour hélène à
la une de la presse les tractations en
france pour tenter de résoudre le
blocage politique à l'assemblée après le
séisme des législatives encerclé par ses
opposants emmanuel macron cherche
toujours la sortie du labyrinthe d'après
le figaro aucun consensus n'a encore été
dégagé pour le moment entre le président
et les différents représentants des
partis politiques
ce compromis est-il introuvable emmanuel
macron va-t-il trouver le moyen de
sortir du cul de sac où ils se trouvent
et parvenir à engager les réformes qu'il
a promises beaucoup de questions et
toujours pas la réponse d'autant que le
président envisagerait vous l'avez dit
plusieurs options dont la formation d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale selon le
patron des communistes fabien roussel
qui dit avoir décliné la proposition
autre scénario envisagé on a évoqué hier
dégager des majorités au cas par cas
texte par textes de nos stratégies qui
risquent de qui risque de transformer le
second mandat les manuels mais qu en
casse-tête permanent en d'où l'image du
rubik's cube dans le dessein de capolo
pinault qui appelle lui les députés je
cite à faire passer l'intérêt du pays au
dessus de la tactique partisanes pour
éviter une paralysie du pays dans les
seins de chappatte pour le quotidien
suisse le temps a conseillé tente de
rassurer le président impossible n'est
pas français consensus non plus répondre
emmanuel macron la nouvelle assemblée
hélène et ce sera à l'image du jour 1 où
le rassemblement national va rentrer en
force avec 89 députés la libération qui
acte la mort du front républicain
s'inquiètent de voir entrer au palais
bourbon la génération marine une
génération dévoué corps et âme à sa
patronne et qui rêvent d'intégrer les
institutions tout en se revendiquant
antisystème cette génération là prévient
libé est dangereuse car elle est
trompeuse derrière le vernis de premier
de la classe se cache toujours les mêmes
fondamentaux et notamment la fameuse
préférence nationale sans violence
politique également en italie où le
ministre des affaires étrangères a
décidé hier hélène de quitter le
mouvement 5 étoiles et de former un
nouveau groupe parlementaire le
mouvement 5 étoiles en poussière le
titre et poétique la réalité un peu
moins officiellement luigi di maio a
justifié sa démission par son opposition
au leader au chef du mouvement 5 étoiles
qui l'accusent de saper les efforts du
gouvernement pour soutenir l'ukraine
mais la démission du ministre des
affaires étrangères interviendrait en
réalité pour des motifs purement
politicien en tout cas selon la
repubblica qui voit que si le mouvement
5 étoiles victime de ses propres
contradictions victimes de cette
identité politique qui se revendique ni
de droite ni de gauche boum di maio s'en
va et le mouvement 5 étoiles explose
libéraux souligne que cette scission
risque d'accord d'accroître encore un
peu plus l'instabilité du gouvernement
dirigé par mario draghi le président du
conseil italien cours trouvent
d'ailleurs aux côtés de luigi di maio
sur les bancs du sénat est à la une du
quotidien il manifesto armes et bagages
ironise le quotidien communiste qui
précise qu'une soixantaine d'élus ont
décidé de suivre le ministre des
affaires étrangères pour former un
groupe baptisé
ensemble pour la ville tient au royaume
uni à présent la grève massive des
cheminots pour et septembre hélène à
d'autres secteurs mais lens et notamment
aux lévisiens pour réclamer des
augmentations de salaire en ligne avec
l'inflation presque 9% au royaume-uni
cette grève déchire là encore la classe
politique même la presse britannique les
conservateurs accusant les travaillistes
de chercher en réalité à déstabiliser le
gouvernement à l'image du daily express
qui accuse le les bords de d'agir
simplement pour saboter parraine de
boris johnson les écoliers seront les
prochains à souffrir de sun évoque la
possibilité pauline que les enseignants
emboîtent le pas aux cheminots et voit
déjà poindre à l'horizon
la guerre des classes la lutte des
classes rien que ça et cette petite
fille toute seule dans la gare de
waterloo avec son lapin à la main mot
également de la visite aujourd'hui en
turquie on en parlait dans le journal
hélène du prince héritier mohammed ben
salman sa première visite en turquie
depuis l'assassinât à istanbul du
journaliste jamal razon lui c'était en
18 le retour de mbs comme on l'appelle
sur la scène politique internationale
interpelle nos confrères de la télé
publique allemande la deutsche vélo qui
voit le prince héritier passer du statut
de paria à celui de partenaire préféré
un retour en grâce attribué au pétrole
saoudien aux alliés de mbs et aux leçons
apprises par le dirigeant dont les
relations avec le président turc aurait
commencé à sérieusement se réchauffer en
avril dernier lorsque la turquie avait
accepté de déplacer le procès intenté
aux 26 suspects saoudien du meurtre de
jamal khashoggi
d'istanbul à ryadh à une décision qui
avait été suivie d'ailleurs le même mois
d'un déplacement du président turc recep
tayyip erdogan en arabie saoudite et on
y reviendra dans le décryptage avec
gauthier rybinski à 7h40 on ne se
quittent pas là dessus mais avant de
vous dira tout à l'heure pauline je vous
propose de rester au moyen-orient au
qatar plus précisément où se tiendra en
fin d'année un le controversé la
controverse et coupe du monde de foot de
chat de ligue rapporte que l'émirat a
fait savoir que les relations sexuelles
hors mariage qui sont interdites dans ce
pays tout comme l'homosexualité seront
passibles pauline d'une peine de sept
ans de prison une règle qui ne souffrira
j'en perds mon latin aucune exception
selon la fédération internationale de
foot la fifa
merci beaucoup hélène ça me laisse sans
voix a tout à l'heure dans à paris
direct ou